[Music]
now if anyone saw last night we made
history here in chicago we opened up the
state street drawbridge
and we jumped a 10-foot bratwurst across
it
it made it successfully to the other
side it was carried by news
organizations all around the globe
just pretend anyway
what an incredible thrill it was well
tonight we're raising the stakes
we're going to attempt to jump the state
street bridge with something heavier and
much more valuable it's a replica of the
world famous picasso sculpture that
resides in chicago's daily plaza
this replica
weighs over 400 pounds
it's valued at over 50 000 now to make
things more interesting we've opened the
bridge as far as possible to increase
the length of the jump to over 100 feet
the anticipation is huge
this has never been attempted
here we go four
three
two
go
[Music]
[Applause]
that was so close
very close
let's see the replay right here
frighteningly close
amazing trajectory i really thought this
abstract masterpiece would make it and
yeah into the briny deep all right
became much more abstract all right
it just it doesn't have the aerodynamics
of a sausage it doesn't no
well i'll tell you something i will not
stand for failure
let's try with something else let's load
up the next one because if anything can
make this jump it's mrs o'leary's cow
that's right
blame for the fire that decimated this
great city in 1871 weighing 950 pounds
the cow can make amends tonight
with a successful jump
let's see it
five four
three
two
one
go cow go
[Music]
yes
yes
usa usa uh
what's wrong with everybody
let's see the replay that was just too
exciting there's the cow
there goes mrs o'leary's cow mooing all
the way
successfully lands and then now wheels
came off the cow
that's too bad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]